hi this is pressed all occur this puzzle
went viral after Google featured it in a
Japanese TV commercial for Nexus 7 can
you make the number 10 from the numbers
1 1 5 & 8 you have to use each of the
four numbers 1 1 5 & 8 exactly once and
you can use the available operations of
addition subtraction multiplication
division and you can group terms with
parentheses you are not allowed to use
exponents 8 plus 1 plus 1 to the power 5
does give you 10 but this is not a valid
solution because you are not allowed to
use exponents so can you figure it out
can you make 10 from the numbers 1 1 5 &
8 give this a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video to see how you
would solve this problem one approach is
to consider the numbers and their
factors 10 breaks down into 2 and 5/8
consists of 3 factors of 2 the number 5
only breaks down into 5 and the number 1
also breaks down into 1 so one way that
you could get to 10 is if you could grab
one factor of 2 from 8 and one factor of
5 from the 5 you would also have to get
rid of the rest of the numbers you can
also get to 2 by having 1 plus 1 but
let's go ahead and think about trying to
grab one factor of 2 from the 8 & 1
factor of 5 from the 5 if we multiply 8
& 5 we get 240 we've overshot our
solution by 4 times so we need to divide
by the rest of the numbers we know that
1 in 1 make 2 so we can put this all
together and say 8 times 5 divided by 1
plus 1 will equal 20 now this is
actually not too far off from our
solution we've doubled we've gotten 2
times as far as 10 so we want to reduce
this by a factor of 2
so we can try and move the terms around
like let's say we move the five over to
the denominator if we do that we take
eight divided by one plus one-fifth and
that gets us to six and two-thirds so
now we're actually we've under shot we
want to get back up higher so we could
do that by reducing the denominator and
changing the sign to a minus and now
magically we've gotten to our solution
eight divided by one minus one-fifth is
equal to ten if you go through the steps
carefully what happens is we've grabbed
one factor from the five and because the
denominator is 4/5 we've reduced eight
by two factors of two so we'll grab one
factor of two from the eight and we've
grabbed the other factor of five from
the five to get us to ten what's very
interesting about this puzzle is that
it's a very unexpected thing that you
would want to divide by one minus 1/5
and the other thing that's interesting
is I went through and I calculated all
the different ways that you could
combine the numbers 1 1 5 & 8
with the operations of addition
subtraction multiplication division and
grouping terms with parentheses and what
I found I've linked the solution in a
spreadsheet it's got over 1,700 entries
and this is the only solution this is
the only way that you can get these
numbers to get to a result of 10 so it's
very interesting puzzle and if you look
through the entries there really no
other ways that you can arrange the
numbers that have a unique solution
that's also interesting it wouldn't be
hard to find out just by looking at the
numbers so it's a pretty cool puzzle and
it's great that Google included it in a
TV commercial thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
also catch me on social media at
pressure Locker and if you liked the
video please check out my books I
provided descriptions of each one in the
video description
you